HIGHLIGHT!
BAD MAN.
THTHIRD QUARTER.
THE LEAD, 13 FOR ON THE OTHER
END.
>> Pete: OF THE
SQUARE. THE BOX ON THE BACK OR
LOOK AT  IT.
AND ROLLS IT IN.SMALL.
LOOK AT WHAT HE DOES WITH THAT
THE HASHTAKEOFF.
HE IS NOT G SURRENDER.
THEY HAVE NOT THE
>> Mark: WOW.
>> Jeff: THAT'S TALENT RIGHT
THERE.IT STOLEN.
BALL DO THAT.
OH, MY
EIGHT THREE-POINT MAKES IN THAT
QUARTER.
S CREATED WITH THE
NINE
LaMELO, IS OUT AND RUNNING AND
BRIDGES IS HUSTLING TO GET INTO
THE PICTURE, HERE  TURNER.
PUTS IT ON THE TURNER.
STARS IN THE NBA.WITH TWO.
>> Stan: THERE'S NO QUESTION. IL
BE ABOUT THEIR PICK-AND-ROLL
DEFENSIN, OTTO PORTER
HOLDS HIS GROUND,
AND 12.
UP AHEAD TO.
>> Eddie: THAT'S FROM HALF
COURT.
MOVE BY
PATTY MILLS TO MAKE HIM SEE
BODIES IN FRONT OF
SEASON.
GOBERT!S SENGUN GET
DONOVAN FROM